L
BEING PLAYED.
>> TOM BRADY SAID THAT
YESTERDAY.
>> NOT SURPRISINGLY I AGREE WITH
TOM BRADY.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> A DECORATED ARMY GENERAL'S
RETIREMENT IS BEING PUT ON HOLD.
THIS STEMS FROM A SERIES OF
TWEETS THAT HE PUT OUT LAST YEAR
IN RESPONSE TO FOX HOST TUCKER
CARLSON SAYING MATERNITY FLIGHT
SUITS MADE A MOCKERY OF THE U.S.
MILITARY AND THE FEMIZATION OF
THE U.S. MILITARY IS OUT OF
CONTROL.
DONOHOE POSTED A VIDEO OF
HIMSELF WITH A FEMALE SOLDIER
SAYING CARLSON COULDN'T BE MORE
WRONG.
A FEW MONTHS LATER HE WENT BACK
AND FORTH WITH A TRUMP SUPPORTER
, WHO IS NOW BANNED FROM TWITTER
AFTER ENCOURAGING SOLDIERS TO
GET VACCINATED FOR COVID-19.
AND OF COURSE THEY'RE REQUIRED
FOR SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEY'RE
DISCHARGED IF THEY DON'T GET IT.
MAX BOOT HAS BEEN ADVISER TO
MANY CANDIDATES AND HAS WRITTEN
A COLUMN FOR "THE WASHINGTON
POST" ASKING WHY IS THE ARMY
PUBLISHING A GENERAL FOR CALLING
OUT MAGA LIES.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING, MAX.
YOU'VE SEEN THIS REPORT.
IT'S NOT PUBLIC, I BELIEVE, TO
THIS POINT.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF REPORTING
ON IT OUT THERE.
THE ARMY IG SAID THAT DONOHOE
EXHIBITED POOR JUDGMENT AND DID
NOT REFLECT AN ARMY CULTURE OF
DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
YOU DISAGREE WHY?
>> I THINK WHAT HE WAS DOING IS
STANDING UP FOR ARMY VALUES.
HE WAS DEFENDING THE ARMY FROM
THESE UNFOUNDED MALICIOUS
ATTACKS FROM FOX NEWS, MAGA
PATROLS, PEOPLE TRYING TO BRING
THE ARMY DOWN BECAUSE THE ARMY
WOULD NOT DO DONALD TRUMP'S
BIDDING AND TRY TO OVERTHROW THE
DEMOCRACY AND NOW THEY'RE
ACCUSING THE ARMY OF BEING WOKE.
IN THE PROCESS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS UNDERMINING THE SERVICE
OF WOMEN IN THE MILITARY.
THEY ARE CASTING ASPERSIONS ON
THE BRAVE WOMEN DEFENDING US AS
WE SPEAK.
ALL THE GENERAL WAS DOING WAS
STANDING UP FOR THE WOMEN,
SAYING HERE'S THE REENLISTMENT
CEREMONY.
THAT IS DEFENDING THE ARMY AND
IT'S A TRAVESTY THAT THE ARMY IS
NOT STANDING UP FOR A GENERAL
WHO IS DEFENDING ARMY VALUES.
>> I FOUND SOMETHING, I BET YOU
FOUND IT TOO, TALKING TO
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS, FOLKS IN
THE MILITARY.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RETAINING WOMEN IN THE MILITARY
AFTER THEY BECOME MOTHER LS IT'S
ABOUT PRESERVING A HUGE
INVESTMENT IN TAXPAYERS DOLLARS
IN TRAINING AND SERVICE AND
THERE'S BEEN AN EFFORT TO MAKE
SURE MATERNITY UNIFORMS ARE
AVAILABLE, INCLUDING FROM
REPUBLICAN MICHAEL WALTS, HERE'S
WHAT HE SAID BACK IN 2020 ON
CNN.
>> THE NUMBER ONE DUTY OF
CONGRESS, IN OUR VIEW, IS TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR MILITARY.
THAT'S MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS WAS REALLY BROUGHT FORWARD
TO ME BY AN AIR FORCE MAJOR I
HAVE ON MY STAFF.
SHE'S A MOM OF FIVE KIDS TO YOUR
POINT IT'S A TREMENDOUS EXPENSE
BUT SHE'S AN AIR FORCE CYBER
WARRIOR, WE NEED HER TO STAY IN
THE MILITARY AND TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE.
AND, YOU KNOW, AS THEY'RE TRYING
TO HAVE A FAMILY, DEAL WITH
DEPLOYMENTS, AND THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES SO I'M PROUD TO WORK
WITH REPRESENTATIVE HOLLAND,
DESPITE WHAT YOU SEE ON THE
NEWS, WE DO COME TOGETHER
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
SUPPORTING OUR MILITARY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED A
MATERNITY UNIFORM LOAN PROGRAM
INTO LAW.
AND THE MESSAGE WITH THAT MAX
WAS TO WOMEN YOU BELONG.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK THE
MESSAGE TO WOMEN IS WITH THIS IG
REPORT?
>> IT'S SENDING A VERY NEGATIVE
MESSAGE.
IT'S SENDING A MESSAGE NOT JUST
TO WOMEN BUT EVERYBODY IN THE
MILITARY, DON'T STAND UP TO
THESE MAGA LIES AND ATTACKS,
DON'T DEFEND YOUR FORCE
OTHERWISE YOU'LL BE PUNISHED FOR
IT, THAT DOES SEND A NEGATIVE
MESSAGE TO WOMEN IN THE MILITARY
FOR SURE AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
I THINK IT'S VERY DEMORALIZING,
SINCE MY COLUMN CAME UP, I SAW
COMMENTARY ON TWITTER AND
ELSEWHERE SAYING WHAT IS THE
ARMY THINKING?
THEY NEED TO GET IT RIGHT.
THEY NEED TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
GENERAL DONOHOE DID NOT DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> THE ARMY IG DIDN'T APPROVE,
CLEARLY, OF WHAT THEY FELT WAS
GENERAL DONOHOE'S SNARK IN SOME
CASES.
DO THEY HAVE A POINT?
>> OH, COME ON.
THIS IS SUCH MILD SNARK BY THE
STANDARDS OF TWITTER, SO
RIDICULOUS WHEN HE'S FACING
THESE EXTREMIST OFF THE WALL
CRAZY ATTACKS ON THE ARMY.
A LITTLE SNARK, OKAY, MAYBE HE
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
BUT THAT IS SUCH A MINOR THING.
HE DOES NOT DESERVE TO